so many people are making jokes about
the fact that Conor Bard has never had
fast food before and I laughed cuz he's
trying to be the greatest hockey player
to ever lived you are and you used to
crush McDonald's with birdie Nichols
after every practice did you pretty much
and what did you eat pregame and what
were dogs no no no pregame I had steak
and potato every day at 12:30 I never
changed my game Day meal but then I get
to the rink and I was so hungry by 4:30
I'd have a hot dog or piece of pizza
sometimes after the first period I'd
order a hot dog you and Bernie Nichols
were McDonald's buddies quite a bit
sounds like Hank Hank eats hamburgers
before every show uh night
us2 over 90 goals six push-ups yeah
seven seven don't cheat me I had seven
let's hit it